freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute gemeinsam mit dave mit
meinem büro partner wir zeigen euch
heute unsere gold to bestell spots
zumindest einen kleinen ausschnitt bei
man muss sagen wir bestellen selbst
essen oder es liegt auch ein bisschen
daran dass max küche noch nicht da ist
aber wir frönen dem bestellt natürlich
geblieben wir nehmen alles auseinander
wenn wir als besteller des selbst habe
schon ganz viel essen bestellt aber
meine absoluten favorite auch weil ich
so häufig dort bestände habe ich noch
nie in den videos gezeigt es ist morgens
wir brauchen frühstück probe stellen wir
kaffee und kuchen ganz genau das ist ein
laden in der kölner innenstadt unweit
von unserem büro was ist dein gut aber
ich habe ein eindeutiges votum bei
kaffee und kuchen das denn ist erstmal
kaffee kuchen ist super vielfältig also
von bagel über bolls über bananen groth
ist wirklich alles dabei und ich glaube
mittlerweile ist der all in brega wo
kadow laxey mein gott du siehst es
meinen ersten bestellung gleich zweimal
zur bestellung hinzufügen gehe ich
komplett mit sondern rein gehen nehmen
wir bräuchten noch weil ich dir und den
zuschauern gerne zeigen möchte eine
summer bau eines super bowl gewesen ich
bin sehr gespannt golden star ron sommer
baut also
zur bestellung hinzufügen das geile ist
ihr sitzt da oben lieferung in 15 bis 25
minuten das ist einfach nur noch krank
also not dafür lohnt es sich in der
großstadt zu ziehen weil ihr werdet
sehen was jetzt gleich kommt ist
geisteskrank mitgelieferte speise und in
dieser zeit also es macht eigentlich gar
keinen sinn mehr zu kochen man ja es ist
so lecker dass ich meine form
ausgesprochen orion heute eine große
manchmal schicken dieser sommer bau in
der kleinen der große rest ist groß dass
eröffnen ja bitte alles schaut euch das
an
es sieht auch so und das finde ich auch
respektabel ist direkt national
instruments
direkt eine story ja jeder beladen ist
lustiges spiegel ein häufig ich weiß
nicht ob du es auch spannend ist scheint
und ich darf als übels rani sogar noch
aber gar nicht mehr heute sondern ich
mache das eigentlich auch gern aber
manchmal was er war nie er ist wunderbar
also wirklich der bagel an sich fast das
wichtigste bei einem wege er ist auch
richtig lecker also safety-car becker
gemacht man sieht auch allein das ist so
detailverliebt hat passt alles so gut
auch die selbst die farben passend
zusammen dass so ein stimmiges trinke
ich möchte nicht dass man es einfach
richtig der wege
führen durch wie weit gehen die besten
wege sich in köln gegessen habe und mit
die besten die ich überhaupt nicht erst
mal so hier mal in new york das wir
jetzt haben die beiden geil aber der ist
der macht alles richtig über dieses
knusprige spiegel an der bagel ist
einfach auch so beträgt so ein bisschen
so richtig schön weich platten körner
drin mal auf das gefühl man ist etwas
was nicht ganz scheiße ist der schein
trügt aber es ist ultra lag das immer
wieder geil ich freue mich jeden morgen
sondern gleich den weg das ist wie der
jüngeren vergangenheit das was mich am
meisten gepfuscht hat also es bestellt
habe zum ersten mal guckt euch diese
beilagen weil die was liebst du an ihren
ich habe noch nie gehört ich glaube es
erdnuss erdnuss cream die da so drauf
ist weil es muss das merkt man dann
immer so ein bisschen mit und das gibt
noch so einen geilen kicker dann mit
rein und die frischen früchte und glaube
es ist so kleidet also man hat einmal so
joghurt und einmal noch etwas anderes
und eins von den beiden ist auch noch
mega geil und erfrischt ich mach dir
nach ich nehme du nimmst und löffel ich
nehme dadurch der berge wanne 11 und 10
gerade für mich kochen von allem etwas
bisschen krank stieß bis in kranj das
bisschen frische liebe ja auch
überhaupt heftig
verzerrt noch scream geschmeckt mega das
ding ist man denkt bei so einer ball
automatisch dass man ein besserer mensch
ist und hier denkt wir uns auch aber es
schmeckt nun dass das ist so ein
bisschen die besonderheit also wirklich
fans ultra lecker für so ein
sommermorgen ein ultra das frühstück
also nicht ohne grund ist dass einer
unserer lieblings daten zum bestellen
für sagen der laden im frühstücks
stellen wir in köln in der innenstadt
aber die nächsten werden die kommen habe
es auch in sich also freundlich nächster
spot mittagessen und ich sage ehrlich
ungelogen wir haben das glaube ich zwei
wochen lang durchgehend gegessen als wir
es gefunden haben und für mich ist
mittlerweile schon fast ein bisschen
drüber durchaus noch wir machen ein
podcast day und ich mache einen podcast
er ist jetzt online wenn ihr das ganze
sehe ich muss euch kurz erschrecken weil
es ist sogar wir haben innerhalb von
vierundzwanzig schon ein podcast
gestartet guckt ihn euch an es ist alles
verlegen video video podcast alles drum
und warschau betreiber der gebet und
mich besser kennt und ja zu sagen
wo wir jetzt bestellen werden war für
mich nach den zwei wochen zwei wochen
das absolute highlight unserer nach haus
super schwer für mich weil irgendwie
irgendwie bastian seine der speisen die
dann durch war du bist immer noch mega
gerne und ich bin jetzt gespannt wie es
nach einem halben jahr pause dürfen wir
sprechen von bamboo des chili und ich
sage euch ehrlich leute ich hätte
niemals gedacht dass ich es so sehr
lieben würde bei chili con carne ist für
mich so ein klassisches schullandheim
menschen wenn ihr denkt dann wisst ihr
habt ihr gar keine ahnung kein spaß beim
bundes chili die haben eine vielfalt von
chilis nicht mehr chili con carne unser
go to ist trotzdem klassisches ballett
sowie also chili con carne ganz wichtig
extrem scharfe liebe es zu essen es gibt
aber auch süßkartoffel chili es gibt
indonesisches saté die mit erdnusssoße
ich glaube ja gar nicht so super viel
ausprobiert weil wir direkt bei bambule
chili kleben geblieben wir sollten das
ist ein anderes ausprobieren ich würde
gerne also ich gehe ganz klassisch als
heute sind die fotos geben ein paar
mulally ich nehme es sehr scharf also da
kommen noch ein paar nach voraussetzung
besser leben ich glaube ich nehme heute
mal das indonesische hat heute irgendwie
extrem genau bitte auch sehr schade sagt
nun gut wir schicken die bestellung raus
und auch hier bin ich mir sicher es wird
einen baum schwarz ich bin gespannt auf
das indonesische jci ich komme in zehn
minuten kommt dass chili aber in zehn
minuten muss ich auch bei meinen termin
sei nicht bedürftig gesprungen ist tut
mir leid ich habe mal wieder alle meine
planung vergessen ich muss zu einem
anderen reden ich würde dir berichten
wie das atelier schmeckt da und viel
spaß bei dem termin auch nicht so
schnell habe ich 200 stellen für mich es
ist soweit leider ohne date aber
verschiedenste portion
chili
wir haben hier das indonesische satici
lieber wir einmal rein das kommt immer
mit couscous nach sehr sehr geil ist
sind hier drin so süßkartoffeln
stückchen und es riecht ultra lecker
alles riecht wirklich sehr sehr deutlich
sehr präsenten ab sagt er sondern er
muss also was ich liebe ja so ein
bisschen sour cream dabei so ein
bisschen frischer koriander und es ist
einfach so viel besser als man denkt ich
könnte mir vorstellen so viele sitzen
gerade vor dem bildschirm
warum feiert er das so ab es ist so ein
unterschätztes gericht wenn es richtig
gemacht wird ist ein genie so krass dass
chili schmeckt so herzhaft die schärfe
kommt so nice dann dazu diese creme
fraiche die das ganze direkt wieder ein
bisschen abmildert couscous ist auch
einfach so eine geile beilage nicht
immer nur nudeln nicht über nur reis ich
liebe es sehr und das ist auch so ein
essen geführt sich nicht scheiße danach
so in chili ist überhaupt nichts
ungesundes du hast dabei bohnen mais und
es ist wirklich so unfassbar lecker
liebe das ist das perfekte essen zu
bestellen können es nach wie vor
eigentlich jeden tag essen jetzt
probiere ich days bestellung das ist so
ein klassisch sind das wirklich
eigentlich nicht scharf bestellen so ein
satellit aber ich probiere mal
motor wieder beim bestellen heute meine
favoriten aber wieder so gut zu heißt es
ist auch wirklich eine ganz klassische
iphone sehen wir wirklich gespannt und
stellen einen weiteren meiner favoriten
heute abend noch die beiden recht
vorgelegt aber ich ging es erstmal die
chilis ultra lecker und kümmere mich
weiter dass unser podcast live geht weil
das passiert gerade alles parallel ist
03 hektisch beste leben wirklich chili
brot euch mal ein gutes chili da wisse
wovon ich rede leute ich sage euch was
ich habe in der zwischenzeit dem podcast
gehört alles online gestellt zwar miese
action jetzt brauche ich etwas zu essen
von bay area burrito burritos ultra
leckeres essen und bay area ist glaube
ich so alt wie youtuber in köln also ich
weiß nicht wo du erinnerst dich
vielleicht auch
ganz gut so waren glaub ich früher alle
dazu ein tag im leben von denen war der
vielleicht sogar auch da ich weiß das
nicht auf jeden fall einen comicladen
und meines erachtens ist der beste
beraten in köln mein gott du bist hier
oben direkt schon angezeigt cipolla
transport es sind eigentlich immer mit
barracuda also mit rindfleisch gibt es
gerade kein ich nehme caritas dazu ganz
wichtig die rose tomato salzer zwar nur
mittel scharf aber wir haben hier im
büro und zuhause gibt es auch immer
verschiedene scharfe soßen die man dann
auch extra drauf machen kann ist aber
einfach ultra lecker zur bestellung
hinzufügen bist du auch ein okay ja was
für ein
sehr gut dann haben jetzt ganz einfach
ich bestellen ist zeigen euch gleich und
ich sage euch so viel er ist gerade kam
der heilige burrito mit extra scharf
ausbilder chips jetzt schon kann man hat
einfach so ein richtiges s&p die man
weiß man hat ist das und da ist man
hektisch wird auch sein hätte so gesagt
500 gramm also ist auf jeden fall
richtig ordentlich geparkt arboretum
auch so ein geiles essen was man so
perfekt essen kann
motto ich finde das fängt schon an dass
die tortilla so richtig schön weich ist
das eher prall gefüllt ist dass er eng
gerollt ist zur venus wurst und es gibt
dazu nicht viel zu sagen außer einfach
reinzuwachsen
motor den fünf jahren in denen ich in
köln bin kann ich ja schon so oft
gemacht und das ist jedes mal genau so
gar nichts daran ist trocken man hat
hier super viel reißen und hier ist
wirklich so viel soße dabei diese pauli
soße dann die projekt ran weil da eben
auch nachos kartierten sind hier auch
wirklich krank haben die damen hat fast
immer zu aber wenn man ihn genießen kann
sollte man ihn genießen schön structure
blackout soße drüber
laut ok wenn du heute nicht dabei sein
kann sich ja auch eingestellt der können
wir uns jetzt rein ich würde sagen das
waren 3 nur drei unserer lieblings fuß
zum bestellen hier in köln ich kann sie
noch im zweiten drittel davon mache ich
mir gern mit einem daumen ist euch
gefällt gleichen formulierung und bis
zum nächsten mal papa mama und ich weiß
jetzt schon im fall auf die eier aber
bewertet bittet im podcast ultra wichtig
fünf sterne bewertung einklappen auf
spotify und sonstwo dankeschön und mein
ganzer mund brennt der hut über todes
lecker danke fürs zustand